we had a brief discussion about um it's
pathfinding and networks right
yeah it's it's about about finding
groups through networks
in your previous video mike pound talked
about the dykstra algorithm and that's
one way of finding your route
through the network it's what we call a
link state algorithm
so today i'd like to talk about a
different way of doing that
the bowman ford a distance vector
algorithm and it's just a different way
of achieving the same thing
we're trying to find our way through a
network it's i guess a gossipy
algorithm so let's imagine all of our
routers are named after colours
and what they want to do they want to
inform the other routers
of their their distance that they have
to travel to get to the routers
so let's imagine i'm the black router
i'm going to give
my routing table to all my neighbors so
let's imagine i'm going to shout out
some of my routes to my neighbours so i
go
hey green router i can get to the blue
router
in one hey blue router i can get
to the green router in one
dixtra imagine it like this the routers
are trying to build up a picture
in their head each router is trying to
build up
a complete map of the network so the
routers are sending each other
it's a link state algorithm they send
each other oh
i've got a link from the black router to
the red router
it costs three add that to your map the
bellman ford album works differently
it's
it's a distant feature algorithm so each
router is telling the other routers
i can get to black in a cost of one
the green router will receive that
information and go oh thank you blue
router
so it's passing around what we call this
routing table
the distance it takes to get to all the
other routers
so let's turn to the old school uh
overhead projector here if you like let
me get this lined up
we've got our lovely line printer paper
here let's have some rooters
so let's have a black green
blue and our red
router and let's assume there's a
certain cost
of travel for each of these paths red
links to black
got a cost of one red links to blue got
a cost of three
black links to green cost one black
links to blue
got a cost of three blue links to black
we've got across one there's our routing
network that we're going to work with
pretty simple but the routers need to
find their way through it let's
imagine we switch on red and
blue first so we've just switched on the
red router we've just switched on the
blue router and they can see
each other and they know that the cost
between them is three
so these blocks represent the distance
if you like it's going to take that
router to get to velvet
so red can see blue in a cost of three
blue can see red in a cost of three so
these blocks the routing table
now let's imagine we're going to switch
on black for the first time
so black when we switch it on we can see
red cost of one blue
cost of one and nothing else
because we haven't yet switched on green
so now with black is switched on
blue can see black red can see black so
they've been added in to the rooted
tables
now we're going to switch on green so if
we switch on green
green can see its neighbors so green you
can see blue
in a cost of three green can see
black in a cost of one but also
blue you can see green
at a cost of three can see green
in a cost of one let me check i've got
this right
but if we've got this all right then
green can see its two neighbors red you
can see it's two neighbors
can see it's three neighbors black
consists three neighbors
now the routers are going to exchange
their routing tables so let's take the
black router and imagine it's going to
send out
its routing tables to its neighbors so
it's going to show and it's going to say
hey
red i can get to red in one blue in one
green in one what are you going to make
of that so when red
sees that red hears for the first time
about green
red didn't previously know about green
so red can now go
i can get to green in the one cost you
told me plus the one cost that takes me
to get to you
so i've got a new route to green red can
also say oh
you can get to blue in just one
brilliant because if i add on the one
it takes me to get to you now i've got a
route to blue
and two that routine table is going to
arrive with green
green's going to say oh you can get to
blue in one
brilliant i've got a cheaper cost to
blue he's going to hear
for the first time about red i can get
to red now
in a cost of two that's brilliant okay
and then when blue here's about the same
routine table
blue has also got cheaper paths
now i think you or i can see
looking at that but we've now got the
cheapest cost path for everything
the routers aren't so clever so what
they need to well they haven't got the
global view of the network so what they
need to do again so let's imagine now
we're ready
we've received that and we've updated
our routing table
we've made changes whenever we make
changes we send on
our routing table so now red is going to
send its rooting table on to blue
red sends that table to blue and blue
learns
that red has a cost of black and white
that's not used to it
it's already got a one cost path got a
cost path to green and two
that's not used to it it would add on
this three
so blue is not going to update its
reason table as a result
if blue doesn't update it through the
table it's not going to send anything on
and that's the essence really of the
bellman ford distance
vector algorithm my guess here is the
trick's going to be in configuring this
right
in setting those numbers yeah yeah
actually well there are
issues with this yeah there are tricks
and little hacks you have to make
what there's some things we haven't
talked about so how often
does it send those what happens when
things go wrong
um so for example
one of the great things about bowman
ford is if
there's good news if a uh a new computer
comes on that spreads through the
network pretty quickly
if a new route came when we saw that
news spreads quickly
there's an issue which i don't i don't
think we can quite cover in this video
where
if a link dies bad news spreads very
slowly because
a red router might think it's still got
a route to black
the black router might still think it's
got a route to red
and they're exchanging with each other
that they've still got that route
even once that route has disappeared
now it's called the count to infinity
problem there's various hacks
to get around that but with a distance
vector algorithms no no real
satisfactory solution
is this something that's used on um is
this
i love your mug by the way show us your
mug there we go look uh the themed mug
it's always computer file we'll have to
get some of those made is this used then
is this
used extensively now absolutely yes this
is this is used very extensively so
the uh this is used in rip rooting
information process but the daddy of
them all are one of the
oldest routine protocols we have um
igrp interior gateway routing protocol
uh used this and then when that became
enhanced interior gateway region
protocol
they they hacked it a little bit and
they added in a little bit of link stay
but the way the way it's really used and
perhaps we don't have time to get into
this you've got an excellent video about
tim griffin
border gateway protocol uses an
extension of distance vector it uses
what we call path vector
where instead of just sending i am the
black router here's my router table and
you've got costs of this
it sends the entire path and that gets
around this whole
um problem with bad news very slowly and
that that
that variant on distance retrograde in
that variant of
bellman ford that's how the big scale
routing of the internet works today
where did bellman ford come from is it
is it a recent thing
no no no this this algorithm dates way
back to the 50s and actually it wasn't
even bellman and ford who discovered it
i can't remember the names of the
original discoveries but uh belgium and
ford weren't the uh original
originators of this algorithm they just
uh popularized it with them
exactly exactly lucky to get the credit
well ford
did a lot of the old algorithms for
networks so there's a lot of algorithms
known for
right so we're here we can't go to s we
can only go to l
that's a nice easy one so i need to find
l so l goes to c
and it's three plus two is five so l
comes in
one column to start with and each of
these nodes within the network
has connections to other nodes this is
how you initialize network